my name is Dan janat and I play arod
Dorian in Assassin's Creed Unity ano ano
Victor dor the beginning of the game
he's just this kind of young young punk
to your health
you boy but then through his association
with the Brotherhood he becomes part of
a much larger fight the French
Revolution the fight for the people to
overthrow their oppressive government
and then he he slowly starts to realize
that there's much more at stake than his
own personal goals the only person that
he really has a relationship with is
Elise Arno and Elise grow up together
and they're always quite close they're
they're sort of young troublemakers
together what should we do
now
listen don't worry they'll never think
to look for us in here my name is Kine B
and I play
Elise at the beginning of the game you
see her very light very playful a little
reckless adventurous running around and
then as that gets older their
relationship their intimacy develops
into something much deeper into
something romantic you seem to have
caused quite a commotion what can I say
you were always a bad influence oh she's
willing to do pretty much any anything
to Avent her father's
death She's Got a quest in mind and
she's not willing to diverge from it at
any cost my name is Alex Evanovich and I
play Donan Al Fran
mad he's a libertin he's a champion for
freedom and not being hindered by
morality I think arold thinks of the
Marquee as a kind of unpredictable Ally
but he quickly realizes is that the
Marquee although he seems a bit mad on
the outside he's actually quite Savvy he
knows what's going
on let's go my name is Brent gford and I
play a uh lesser known historical figure
of the time a dude named uh Napoleon
bonapart I love the way that the writers
of ACU have created the character um
through the dialogue he's very
intelligent and he uses that command of
the language to influence people and to
get what he wants and that was a lot of
fun for me to play as an actor
Napoleon's probably one of the few
people that Arno feels this guy knows
what's going on he's clearly a smart guy
a strong leader a great tactician my
name is Bruce tins more and I play
Maximillian robp he's a bit of a pedant
he's a bit of a showoff a bit
pretentious Arno is aware of what robis
Pier is capable of and he's he's a he's
a Madman as far as Arno can tell this
guy is nuts and he's leading France into
ruin I don't think he was drunk on power
power but he was drunk on
something thank God you made it sir the
commune stands with you thank you
Sergeant your loyalty does you credit
I've brought my own thing to the table
and hopefully I haven't disappointed the
fans because if I have they're going to
kill
me
make
history Assassin's Creed Unity pre-order
from Amazon for three bonus offers the
guillotine spend a win game get a chance
to win prizes every Friday the explosive
chemical Revolution Mission and an
exclusive unlockable weapon pre-ordered
today at
Amazon